Speaker 1: As many of you know, we've been taking
the real kind of systemic authoritarian risk in
the United States much more seriously lately,
and when we talked about the possibility of a
repeat in 2024 of what the Republican Party under
Trump attempted in 2020, it's no laughing matter.
We also talked earlier this week about the warning
from three retired military generals that if you
had the ranking upper echelon of the military
supportive of something like what Donald Trump
tried to do in 2020, you could have very different
results because you could have a military involved
coup in the United States. There is now another
new commentary from a Canadian professor who is
warning that the United States could actually
fall to a right wing dictatorship by 2030.
This is a very interesting article. Not very
long. I encourage you to read it. We're going to
link to it. And it says that a Canadian political
science professor has warned that the U.S. could
be under a right wing dictatorship by the end
of the decade. This is Thomas Homer Dickson,
founding director of the Cascade Institute at
Royal Roads University in British Columbia.
He is urging Canada to safeguard itself against
the possible collapse of American democracy,
he wrote in the Globe and Mail. By
2025, American democracy could collapse,
causing extreme domestic political instability,
including widespread civil violence. By 2030,
if not sooner, the country could be governed
by a right wing dictatorship. Much of the
professor's hypothesis centers around the idea
of Trump returning to the White House in 2024.
Trump is widely expected to run for office again.
I don't know about that. I don't know about that.
He's it's considered that he may. And Mr
Homer Dickson anticipates a Republican
held state legislatures will refuse to accept a
Democratic presidential win. That is a concern,
and we've talked about that so many times now,
this idea that they wanted to push on pence
for January six, 2020, and we're almost
at the one year anniversary of that day.
The idea was states that so I'll break it
down from the beginning before the election.
Say you're worried that there's going to be a
lot of voter fraud because of mail in ballots
after the election when Joe Biden won a bunch of
these states. They claim we can't actually trust
the results. And then the third part which they
didn't do, they wanted Mike Pence to do, but they
didn't do would have been Mike Pence or whoever
is vice president. But it was Pence in 2020 at
the time of the certification of those electoral
votes of the acceptance of those electoral votes.
Rather, the certification was on December 14th
or so. January six was we're going to tally these
four pence to say, we don't believe that these
are genuine results. So instead of allowing
the Democratic electors from Arizona to vote, we
are going to seat an alternate slate of electors
to vote for Trump. That was the idea. The concern
now is they had the idea in 2020, but they didn't
do it, that they're actually going to do it in
2024. Homer Dixon is a well-respected scholar
of violent conflict. He says Canada should be on
guard against the unfolding crisis in Washington,
D.C., spreading northward. He said quote A
terrible storm is coming from the south and
Canada is woefully unprepared. Over the past year,
we've turned our attention inward, distracted by
the challenges of COVID reconciliation and
the accelerating effects of climate change.
Speaker 4: But he says,
Speaker 1: now we must focus
on the urgent problem of what to do about the
likely unraveling of democracy in the US. We
need to start by recognizing the magnitude of the
danger. If Trump is reelected, even under the more
optimistic scenarios, the economic and political
risks to our country will be innumerable.
Some might view such warnings as hyperbolic,
but the political scientist is steadfast in his
view that a new Trump administration with
little in the way of internal opposition
could seek to deliberately undermine its northern
neighbor. Canada is worried, and we're worried
about the same thing, and the crazy thing is that
we sort of just have to wait and see what happens.
And what I mean by that is. Trump was impeached
twice, not convicted. Nothing really came of it.
Corruption in government isn't changing for the
better in any real way. We got a warning from
three retired generals yesterday that if the
military were on the side of what Trump wanted
to do, they might actually have been able to
make it happen and it could happen in 2024.
And unfortunately, most Americans don't even
realize what's going on. I want to play for you.
This is really interesting. This is a clip
from Joe Rogan talking to Jordan Peterson,
and it applies to this. They are talking about
COVID guidelines. This is the crazy thing. They're
talking about COVID guidelines. We're talking
about actual authoritarianism from a government
and even though what they are talking about
doesn't apply, OK? This actually does apply
to what's going on right now
Speaker 4: is don't understand
how it gets to the point.
Speaker 1: Actually,
they may not even have been talking about COVID
here. They may have been talking about. It's not
even clear what they're talking about, they're
not talking about Trump ism and authoritarianism
of that sense, but it would apply when
Speaker 4: things get to terrible places. One
tiny step at a time. You know, if I encroach, if
I encroach on you and I'm sophisticated about it,
I'm going to encroach two mm. I'm going to
encroach right to the point where you start,
start to protest and I'm going to stop, then I'm
going to wait. Then you're going to calm down,
then I'm going to encroach again, right to the
point where you protest. Then I'm going to stop,
then I'm going to wait and I'm just going
to do that forever. And before you know it,
you're going to be back three miles from where
you started and you'll have done it one step at
a time and then you'll go, Oh, how I understand.
Speaker 1: Rogan, this is this is from a little
bit ago. But Rogan posted it yesterday, pretty
obviously signaling that it's about COVID,
but it applies perfectly to January 6th, the
coup attempt and what we may be facing yet here.
Speaker 4: And the answer was, well, I pushed
you a little farther than you should have gone,
and you agreed. And so then I pushed you a
little farther than you should have gone again.
And you agreed. And if anybody's interested in
this sort of process and this is a horrifying
book, if you want to read about how this
process works, you can read a book called
Ordinary Man by Robert Browning doing it.
Speaker 1: So it perfectly, perfectly,
perfectly applies to what we are seeing now.
And it's not that people necessarily accept,
but it's that not enough is being done to
stop it from happening again. And incredibly
relevant commentary from Jordan Peterson
not applied to what it should be applied to.